Ви прийшли у гараж-хаб,
це — публічна майстерня.
Насправді все сталося так, що ми починали,
коли вчилися в університеті на фізико-технічному факультеті.
Нам дуже подобалась фізика і
ми займалися цим дуже довго.
В університеті дали свою лабораторію.
І це була така кімната з обладнанням 1985 року,
яке нам, насправді, не можна було навіть чіпати.
Нам просто дали чотири стіни, стелю, підлогу і все.
У 2014 році ми посіли друге місце
на міжнародному турнірі фізиків,
а це достатньо таки престижний рівень.
Але ми програли Франції в фіналі.
Коли ми повернулися з того турніру у Швейцарії,
то ми зрозуміли, що так не може бути далі,
що нам потрібен якийсь свій простір.
Нам треба, щоб нас вахтьорша
не випихала з лабораторії о 10 вечора.
І ми почали шукати своє приміщення,
але це було дуже дорого —
у нас не було ніяких грошей,
окрім своєї стипендії.
Нас було лише четверо і ми орендували один гараж.
Це був такий незалежний простір,
у якому ми займалися фізикою.
Ми вирішили, що на базі цього гаража будемо
далі готуватися до наступного міжнародного турніру,
що ми і зробили.
Ми виграємо регіональний етап,
ми виграємо національний етап...
Ми їдемо, у 2015 році це була Варшава,
на міжнародний турнір фізиків
і ми займаємо твм перше місце.
Ми повертаємось, у нас є кубок,
тобто ми виграли найпрестижніше командне змагання
для студентів у світі — з орендованого гаража.
Ми повертаємося з цим кубком, ось тут він стоїть...
Ми зробили з нього лампу,
бо сенсу більше ніякого від нього немає.
Бо коли ми повернулись: університет був дуже задоволений.
«Ура, міжнародні змагання, фізтех —
чемпіон світу, і так далі».
І це було класно, ми розуміємо,
що для університету це велике досягнення.
Потім з'явилися деякі проблеми і, так чи інакше,
за наступні декілька років ми відійшли від університету.
Як один з кейсів — ми втратили свої стипендії
в тому році, коли ми виграли турнір,
бо це потребувало від нас дуже
великої концентрації саме на цьому змаганні.
Ми не могли відвідувати пари,
університет перестав бути для нас таким авторитетом,
до якого треба приходити, і витрачати
все своє студентське життя саме на навчання.
Плюс у нас тоді вже був гараж, це такий простір,
де ми могли самоактуалізуватися через технології.
Ми продовжували це робити
і за наступні два роки один гараж
перетворився на два, на три, на чотири.
Ми познайомилися з Дімою,
він до нас приєднався. Діма — архітектор.
Так, я закінчив навчання через силу,
і я теж шукав місце,
де я можу використати свої знання на практиці.
Я почав шукати свою майстерню, зустрів хлопців,
ми посиділи, послухали музику, випили пива,
і вирішили, що я до них переїжджаю.
Ми зняли одразу третій гараж,
вони мені допомогли,
ми зробили там підлогу, пофарбували стіни.
Ми займаємося дуже великою кількістю різних речей.
Коли до нас приходять люди, вони питають:
«Ви робите речі з фанери?»
Потім вони бачать металеве обладнання і кажуть:
«Ви робите речі з металу?»
І ми їм кажемо, що ми робимо будь-що,
тобто, як кажуть, «the sky is the limit».
Але для того, щоб вмістити
це у невеличке приміщення,
нам потрібно було дуже багато подумати.
До нас приходять люди і кажуть:
«Ми хочемо стати резидентами».
Ми з ними спілкуємось, переконуємось,
що вони дорослі і адекватні люди,
вони проходять короткий курс техніки безпеки,
і все, ми їх випускаємо в майстерню.
Кажемо, якщо ви чогось не вмієте —
ми вас навчимо.
І можемо проводити їм додаткові курси.
Гараж-хаб це, по-перше, ідея
того, що будь-хто з орендованого гаража
може почати робити те, що йому подобається,
і довести це до якогось рівня,
коли це не є просто хобі.
А по-друге, що це може також паралельно
стати не якоюсь незрозумілою структурою,
яка є недоступною, бюрократизованою і так далі,
а це може стати справжньою соціальною платформою,
яка може творити зміни у суспільстві.
Ми не кажемо, що університет — це погано.
Ми кажемо, що, на жаль, зараз він у такому контексті,
що не виступає «третім простором»,
де можна займатися тим, чим тобі хочеться.
І коли є така ніша, є такий вакум — це нормально,
що з'являються люди, які цей вакум заповнюють.
Для того, щоб тренд запустився — потрібно,
щоб були якісь локальні агенти змін,
які ці тренди використовують,
які ними живуть, можна сказати.
І, мені здається, ми це робимо тут.
Якщо ти працюєш в ІТ,
то це означає, що ти секс-символ, правильно?
Тобто це і є та сама штука.
З інженерією є те саме, але десь на 10 років пізніше.
Зараз ми живемо у той час,
коли можна власноруч зібрати обладнання,
яке управляється комп'ютером і робить речі,
котрі можна запустити в космос.
І це може зробити будь-хто,
навіть студенти в орендованому гаражі.
Ми не є якась країна третього світу.
У нас класні фахівці, у нас класні люди,
які можуть своєю головою створити унікальні речі.
У нас в Україні є стартапи,
є класні технологічні проекти,
треба просто щоб суспільство розуміло цінність інженерії,
щоб батьки не відмовляли своїх дітей
йти на інженера, бо немає що потім робити.
Але це вимагає інфраструктурних змін,
це вимагає багато інших таких речей, які вже йдуть далі.
Але перше, що треба зробити — цю стіну треба проламати,
треба зробити так, щоб люди хотіли ставати інженерами.
І це робиться саме тут.